يعرضوا برنامج الجزيره التحقيق ما خفي
اعظم الذي يبث مساء اليوم الجمعه يعرض
لقطات ولقاءات حصريه تكشف جانبا من كواليس
كتيبه جنين التابعه لسرايا القدس لجراحه
العسكري للجهاد الاسلامي وايضا مجموعه
عرين الاسود في نابلس
من مواكبتي شراره المقاومه في الضفه
الغربيه وتمددها على الرغم من الاستهداف
الاسرائيلي المتواصل لها والتعقيدات
الامنيه التي تواجهها ويعرض التحقيق الذي
يحمل عنوان خارج الحسابات تفاصيل تنشروا
لاول مره عن بعض عمليات مجموعات المقاومه
التي حدثت مؤخرا في الضفه الغربيه
التحقيق الذي يقدمه زميل تامر مسحل سيكشف
ايضا جوانب خفيه من المواجهه الامنيه
المستمره على جبهات عدى بين المقاومه
الفلسطينيه والاحتلال اخفي اعظم خارج
الحسابات ياتيكم على شاشه الجزيره
ومناصتها المختلفه اليوم عند العاشره وخمس
دقائق مساءا بتوقيت مكه المكرمه